we cannot wait to watch my carry tied it
out with James Packer and right if
you're watching well Martha Stewart
tells us she expects you to spare no
expense they got money that's the one
thing they have for Martha also has some
wedding advice for people who don't have
a billionaires budget hi Bailey
I heard that thank you so much for
coming I understand that you have a
slight dilemma any bride needs help
although the brides are pretty strong
minded and strong-willed the original
domestic goddess helps friend and
bride-to-be Bailey on tonight say yes to
the dress and if you're gonna ask Martha
be prepared for the truth you try that I
did - you said it might be out of my oh
don't think about the budget from the
beginning of her choosing till the
actual filming of the segment she
probably lost ten pounds and the dresses
were not exactly fitting her perfectly
what are your thoughts you have to
translate Lee I can't say oh that's a
horrible dress that she's already chosen
I just think it's a little rigid so much
fun
not everyone can have Martha consult on
their I Do's but she says the next best
thing is her book Martha Stewart
Weddings ideas and inspiration I don't
like to use the word Bible but it is the
Bible for bride one of the key pieces of
advice you give in your book you really
want to have a day that you will
remember fondly so we advise if you can
afford it to have a wedding planner help
you with lots of those details Martha
says budget wisely the most costly items
she says spend 40% for food 10 to 15%
for the reception venue and rentals and
10% for fashion including that dress and
the biggest Bridal mistakes overreaching
it's one thing I spending too much money
is another thing going into debt and the
third is to get too nervous and to be
angry and frustrated during the whole
planning process she's not planning
Mariah's wedding to James Packer but has
a suggestion
over-the-top lavish lavish lavish in
this wedding I'm sure it's gonna be a
SPECT
she's marrying one of the richest men in
Australia Martha got married in 1961 and
was a do-it-yourselfer even back then
and I made my own dress
that's me and I made the Hat the little
pillbox which was this style and my
waist was 19 inches how big is your
waist by the way your head is supposed
to be the same circumference as your
waist on your wedding day it should be
probably your waist should be a little
bit less than your head okay baby we